alan dershowitz is of course a retired
end eminent law professor at Harvard
he's also the author of the book the
case against impeaching Trump and he
joins us tonight professor thank you
very much for coming on so all of this
is kind of coming out as we're reporting
it and it's hard to assess but I just
want to get to the core allegations once
again
so you heard Catherine Harridge say
repeatedly that the special counsel says
that Michael Cohen is in contact with
the Russians at various points how would
that be criminal under what
circumstances would that be criminal do
you think well it would only be criminal
if for example this is a hypothetical
the campaign or President Trump or
somebody in his behalf offered Putin a
penthouse apartment at the top of the
tower in exchange for getting a permit
to build the tower that would be
arguably criminal under the federal
Corrupt Practices Act right short of
that it's very very hard to see this
what I think we're seeing is a coming
attraction to what the report will be
and I think the report will set out a
circumstantial case based on all of the
lying that's taking place a
circumstantial case for arguably
political sins but I don't see any
crimes collusion itself is not a crime
using information given by Russia to
WikiLeaks would not be a crime unless
the campaign participated with WikiLeaks
in the hacking itself and there's no
evidence to support that so what I'm
afraid is going to happen is this
special counsel whose job it is only to
find crimes not sins only crimes will
blur the line between crimes and sins
and write a report designed to put the
president in a bad light but in the end
they won't be able to find any specific
violations of federal criminal statutes
unless they stretch these vague laws
like obstruction of justice beyond any
recognition so is it a prosecutor's job
constitutionally to paint a politician
or
anyone in a quote bad light without
charging him with relevant crimes that's
not in his perfect no it's worse it's
worse than improper it's
unconstitutional the grand jury has a
specific function it's supposed to only
indict or not indict indeed prosecutors
generally don't issue reports for that
reason because they only hear one side
of the case they don't hear the other
side there's no questions amination of
witnesses that's why it's regarded as
wrong for prosecutors to issue reports
that's what Comey did wrong he should
never have gone beyond saying we're not
indicted Hillary Clinton exactly I know
it should have been a Justice Department
official and now I think it's wrong for
there to be a public report laying out a
political case now at the very least
what has to happen is the new Attorney
General has to if he receives the report
say I'm not making it public until the
other side has had a chance to rebut it
and file its own report then you get two
political reports one from each side and
the public and judge but this sounds
like a distortion of what prosecutors
ought to do prosecutors ought to do up
and down indict not indict if you have
the evidence of crime indict otherwise
shut up so when the special counsel's
office releases documents as they did
today that make cryptic references to
meetings with Russia without explaining
why this is relevant to the public
interest or a legal does it raise the
suspicion that this is a manipulative
public relations move rather than a
legal one well it raises the suspicion
that the final report will also include
allegations of political sin rather than
specific crimes and that's just not the
proper role of Special Counsel or any
prosecutor and I hope it doesn't happen
I hope that Muller who has a generally
good reputation as a prosecutor will
remember that his job essentially was to
uncover crimes that occurred before he
was appointed at the moment most of the
crimes he's uncovered occurred after he
was appointed lying lying to Congress
lying to prosecutors and
crimes that are unrelated his mandate
mana for financial crimes : taxicab
crimes the only crimes he seems to have
found relating to Russia are by Russians
and that was not part of his mandate
number one - number two
nobody's going after these Russians
they're not gonna be sent to the United
States they're not coming to Disneyland
where they can be arrested so that's
pretty moot so very quickly one final
more general question you've watched our
legal system and participated in it for
many decades now is it common for
prosecutors good good people people of
integrity to become caught up in a kind
of vortex of zealot tree where they kind
of lose sight of the law and become
really focused on destroying people well
I think that's the problem with Special
Counsel because you come in and there's
somebody out there or people out there
with targets on their back and in this
case he went after so many people who
had close connections to the president
in an attempt to get him you don't have
to believe me listen to judge Ellis who
presided over the metaphor case he was
very critical of how the special
prosecutor is squeezing people not only
in order to make them sing but in some
cases people are composing because they
think the better the story the better
the deal it also gives an app a lesson
an object lesson the criminal defense
lawyers be careful when you make a deal
because when you make a deal with the
prosecutors they can really come back
and hurt you look at what happened to
Cohen he made a deal the special counsel
says he's cooperated but the US attorney
in New York says he still ought to get
substantial jail time that's why in 53
years of practicing law I have very very
rarely made deals or made pleased with
prosecutors because I basically don't
trust them I don't trust the system the
system today is so skewed in favor of
prosecutors and against defendants we
may be losing perspective this I just
want to remind our viewers on our way
out that you were not a figure on the
right you are not a trump voter you're
merely defending what you think is our
tradition of law and I know I appreciate
and I've been saying the same thing for
55 years I don't say the same thing for
55 years I've expressed the same
criticism of prosecutors whether they go
after Democrats or Republicans
amen calendar shows thank you very much
thank you